all right guys we're here today to watch
the prologue for jurassic world dominion
i'm excited for this movie i thought uh
falling kingdom while not my favorite in
the franchise to say the least i thought
the ending note left it for something
very unique for the jurassic world
franchise to venture off into i'm
excited john are you excited i just
couldn't be more excited i just saw the
lost world jurassic park again over the
weekend and in preparation for this one
video
how'd you know they were going to
release this
beats psychic ability always on top of
this
right man so because this is universal
we might have to do some you know
footage
a little a little crappy crop thingy
just because uh it's always instant
instant claims or blocks with these guys
but it's jurassic world so gotta try
[Music]
never going to be able to hear the theme
song again
[Music]
oh i didn't even catch that it took me a
second
cool
don't do the lion king theme song
everything the light touches
is that the same mosquito that they
caught yeah it's the one with the dna
from the first one
beautiful absolutely beautiful
huh
ankylosaurus
[Applause]
just keep expecting a david attenborough
narration now
this is like the first jurassic movie to
go to the actual dinosaur timeline
unless it's the present day
horned migration
i love this the world used to be theirs
that's a trap waiting to happen
what's up
oh
wow
wow
oh
land on the other no it's that mosquito
[Music]
animals
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's wrong with you guys guys
there are people screaming everywhere
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
i got chills
oh no
oh god
settle down kid she can't run forever
[Music]
that was exciting yeah that was really
exciting that wasn't bad at all i'm not
gonna lie i actually kind of liked the
first half of that a little bit more
i was enjoying just being in the actual
past and this is that's the first time
jurassic park
through all this time has decided to
actually do a sequence that just plops
you as a viewer
right into
the time from 65 million years ago i
don't know whether it was the
implication that that is the t-rex the
same t-rex that they eventually cloned i
think is
that's what i took out of it and knowing
just how movies work now it has to be a
significant t-rex to the canon overall
so i don't know if it's just a nod
towards it or if no it's that one right
there yeah exactly you guys there are
jurassic park fans out there who would
know better than us who would probably
be able to tell yeah you could tell by
the same
scale in the little hair or what i don't
know whatever you guys can pick up on on
the
structural features i love seeing that
you know it's a cool complementary
effect of the dinosaurs used to rule the
world this planet was theirs and then it
was not theirs anymore now they're
coming back to reclaim what's once was
their own dinosaurs versus humans yeah
it's cool
it's kind of fun it's it's fun this this
had a little bit more of that like
heightened summer blockbuster fun it was
a little bit refreshing comparatively to
what we kind of get with the prologues
and all the jurassic park movies i i
thought this was something a little bit
different and it kind of reminded me of
like uh like an older movie
yeah
not exactly a documentary what's the
genre of word i'm looking for here
something that was more not jason and
the hero
that's about the the freaking oh like a
ray harry housing kind of thing i'm just
like yeah you're the characters of the
dinosaurs yeah there's no humans you're
just going to watch that it's like the
land before time yeah or a good dinosaur
without narration or the good dice or
another or dinosaur yeah they're a bunch
of leave your favorite dinosaur focused
feature down below it's funny this gave
yeah two flavors one was very much sort
of enveloping you and just like it's i
don't know if you can make a whole movie
out of prehistoric
they're not even jurassic period
dinosaurs but you know like prehistoric
times like this but i thought it was
really refreshing to have something that
was all visual and tone and just you're
watching in a sort of nature
documentary-esque way these animals just
doing what they do and being in nature
and then cutting forward you it's like
totally meta it's like you know this
t-rex is trumping through a movie
theater you know people are spraying
popcorn everywhere that's gonna be us it
is that thing of because of the past two
movies when you cut to the present i'm
always a little bit like uh
i guess we gotta go back and you know
deal with whatever wacky characters are
gonna throw at us but this did get me
excited just for the overall you know
tone maybe being kind of nice in between
for the past two movies because i didn't
love jurassic world's tone so much i
like jurassic world fallen kingdoms a
bit better even though that movie's way
wackier so i'm hoping this movie maybe
can bridge the difference on the
opposite spectrum
i thought jurassic world was a blast
nowhere near the quality of
jurassic park but i thought that was a
blasty blast that had fallen kingdom
really i i kind of hated that movie it's
not mistaken i don't even want to
re-watch it but that's fair
that's absolutely fair but this one is
it's called travero right is he
returning i think he's back yeah yeah
yeah we we could look it up but we're
short on time we we don't have 30
seconds we'll just take the take a
gamble and assume we're correct i like
that like summer
uh high octane
pulse pounding intensity like it's a
different flavor of jurassic park
yeah it's funny to me it's like super
entertaining it just looks like a romp
so yeah when you're doing that you know
you got like dumbasses who are like you
mean to tell me
those three people watching the movie
wouldn't be like what is that sound or
why is my car shaking yeah people making
out like idiots watch them die let's
watch these idiots die yeah that was
amazing what more can we say yeah
absolutely
and i mean having just watched uh you
know lost world this is like you know
you like the extended version of the
finale exactly it's funny it's like they
broke the movie in half they made fallen
kingdom is the first half of of uh
jurassic park ii and now this will be
that end sequence you wish was the whole
movie but hopefully stretched out to the
whole movie yeah that's exactly what it
is and i'm looking forward to it
i am too in spite
it's not just the t-rex there's a whole
bunch of dinosaurs yeah yeah and chris
pratt's going to kick all their ass
that's right he's going to have blue and
he's going to have like even more
raptors on his side he's going to have
like an army of raptors by the end of it
i forget about weird clone girl yeah i
don't really like fallen kingdom
oh god because it's stupider oh no but
the tone is so difficult
cheesy monster movie oh [ __ ] does not
embrace the cheese though that was the
problem with it ah fair i don't know the
first one just like i hated all the
characters and and it took a lot of the
yeah
all the characters and the other one
they were way more i didn't like them
they were more fun to watch die in the
second place oh yeah i hated the tone of
the second one and i thought it's all
serious and [ __ ] the second one at least
addressed some of the issues with the
lead characters and made them a little
less stiff
sure
that auction characters were uh they
were so good they're smart characters
they were almost as good as the vips and
squid game yeah guys what did you think
about this footage i personally thought
it looked great
and maybe maybe it'll do a godfather
part two thing where they cut back and
forth between the prehistoric times i
knew it was you blue and then the
present day time and you watch the
stories come together i would love that
more prehistoric please all right more
merchandising coming your way at
universal studios
guys leave your thoughts down below
thanks so much for letting us know this
was out
and we'll catch you guys soon